[Music]
so
in your own work you've decided to open
source
projects that you have initiated on your
team
yes what convinced you to open source
these tools what drove you to make these
tools open source rather than keep them
internal and proprietary
yeah various reasons of course we're
excited to share
our knowledge in whatever we are doing
um
i have a long background as a scientist
where yeah what we always did was you
know
we we we would always share you know we
would publish we would share our work
because it's like second nature to me
and of course it's it's much more
exciting to
uh yeah to make your work and your
knowledge available to others just like
it's very useful we can use that
knowledge do you or your team contribute
back to any community driven open source
projects
we do uh not not as much
it's usually on an individual level so
we use packages maybe there are bugs
yeah we will we will submit merge
requests
if there's stuff not not working but
when it comes to like the bigger
packages like in non-focus
let's say you want to get something
committed to pandas
yeah actually my one of my bosses did
that a couple months ago and he had like
100
100 comments that he had to go through
so that could actually be quite a bit of
work but in general we do
not so much but yes we do max i
understand one of your team members is
going to speak at pi data global
are you excited to see their talk can
you tell us a little bit about what
they'll be speaking about
yes it's actually one of the people that
i work with closely
she's called lorraine del meda
she's a data scientist working in london
actually our team is spread out over
multiple places
and she will be talking about entity
matching
advanced entity matching at scale
[Music]
you